congratulations on a very good game yeah
thank you
i'm not sure if it was a good game um i
i got a piece very early on in the game
but then
um
i think my technique was not so good
um i didn't play really well after that
and then i allowed this counter play
uh which was not needed but okay somehow
i won in the end are you sometimes too
hard on yourself because you find fault
with a lot of your wins ah no i think
this game uh
it was not a good technique maybe um
because i had a lot of counter play uh
my king was
very open and uh with less time it could
go either way so i'm just happy to win
i have one more question there's so
there's some of our viewers who's very
curious about your your mark in your
forehead the white mark can you tell me
what that means for you um
like
i do it um
because my mother my mother said it very
early on so i it's just my practice i do
it
every time
every day and does it bring luck um i'm
not sure
um
yeah i'm just not sure sometimes
sometimes not good luck to you thank you
thank you